He was the child from hell,
born into royalty with a deformity that
put a lifelong chip on his shoulder.
But by the time he
became ruler of Germany,
this grandson of Queen Victoria had
grown to hate the British hate the French
and well paid just about every other
European power. Over the next 20 years,
he orchestrated the tension that exploded
into the nightmare that was world war
one and in this week's biographics we
uncover the mixed onto life of Kaiser
Wilhelm.
The seconds
the Charles who wants to
become Kaysville home.
The second was born Friedrich Advil home,
Victor Albert von, the Hohenzollern.
The date was January the 27th 1859 and
the place was Pottstown and what was then
the state of Prussia. His father was
Prince Frederick Ville, helm of pressure,
while his mother was the
English Princess Victoria.
The birth was not an easy one with the
doctor having great difficulty getting
the baby out of the birth
canal as a result of ill homes,
left arm was virtually useless, being
significantly shorter than his other arm.
Many historians believe that
Ville hymns deformity get stunted.
His emotional growth and contributed
to as reckless behavior in later life.
What is certain is that he was extremely
self conscious about his empowered on
and constantly sought ways to hide.
The deformity of Wilhelm was second
in line to be the king of Prussia.
He was also the first grandson
born to England's Queen Victoria.
Victoria was fond of the child considering
to be a well mannered young step from
the start and whether he demonstrated a
volatile disposition at the age of four
he was taken to England to
attend to royal wedding.
Parts of his tiny uniforming created
a small dagger. During the ceremony,
Wilhelm began fidgeting.
His uncle's standing alongside
nudged him and told him to be still,
but the fiery four year old
he was having none of it.
He pulled out the dagger and
to threaten to stab his uncle.
Then when the uncle attempted
to restrain him Ville, I'm busy.
Then the leg grandmother,
Victoria would not have been amused,
but fortunately she never found out about
the incidence. Villareal was another.
It was constantly worrying about her son.
In addition to having to
contend with is angry manner.
She felt guilty about his arm deformity,
irrationally blaming
herself for the condition.
She worried that it would prevent him
from fulfilling his obligations as add to
the throne.
One thing she was determined not to let
the arm deformity do was stop her son
from riding a horse.
As a result,
she ensured that he began taking horse
riding lessons at the age of eight the
lessons were hell for the future ruler.
He constantly fell from the horse largely
due to the lack of balance calls to
buy his deformed arm.
Yes.
After weeks of persevering often
with tears rolling down his cheeks,
he managed to overcome his limitations
becoming a capable horsemen.
In 1871 the German and
officially came into being.
It was to be ruled by the king of Prussia.
12 year old veil home was now second in
line to become the head of two nations
and his preteen years.
Phil home had been privately
tutored from the age of 13 however,
he was sent to the Friedrichs,
gymnasium and castle.
He proved to be a talented students
performing well in all of his studies.
He graduated at the age
of 18 and 1877 grand.
Mother Victoria was sent delighted with
our special boy that she awarded him the
order of the Garter, one of the highest
that she could have bestowed upon him.
After graduating, he attended
the University of Bonn
for the next four years.
He studied law and politics.
In addition to his formal studies,
Ville helm was inculcated into the
military ideals of Prussian manliness.
This concept of the tough disciplines
military men was closely aligned with that
oppression.
Nationalism,
although his mother tried hard to impress
the Victorian ideals of liberalism
upon him, Wilhelm shuns them
in favor of the Prussian way.
Wilhelm was military service began at
the age of 21 he was given the rank of
first left tannins in the first regimen
to foot guards spaced in Potsdam.
He talked to army life
like a duck to water.
He later said the following
about his time in the military.
I really found my family, my
friends, and my interests.
Everything of which I up to that time
had to do without above all his time in
the military and viewed the young
prince with self confidence.
See became assurer in his bearing and he
began to speak with an air of authority.
However,
the more he developed as a military man,
the more distant he
became from his parents.
He viewed them as being too invested in
British and liberalism at the expense of
Prussian nationalism.
Wilhelm was 21 when he met his future
wife or Augusta Victoria of [inaudible]
Holstine,
but she was also known as donor.
It wasn't as finessed foray of the heart
a couple of years before he had fallen
hard for his first cousin, Princess
Elizabeth of has said dumb starts,
but she had refused his marriage proposal,
not say with Donna,
and the couple got engaged in 1880 they
were married in 1881 and they'd go on to
have seven children following
his marriage Ville home games,
a powerful ally and the
form of Prussian statesmen,
Otto von Bismarck who saw the prince as
a means of advancing his own political
career. He would use the buy as a means
of gaining an advantage over that.
Parents with Bismarck pulling strings
Ville home began to be sent on diplomatic
missions.
The first was to Saint Petersburg to
attend to coming of age ceremony for 16
year old son of a bitch, Nicholas,
but the haughty and arrogant Ville.
How did not make a favorable impression
on Sar Alexandra up two years later in
1886 villain went with his grandfather
to visit the Austrian Hungarian emperor
from Joseph.
This trip went Besa Lanciani because
Ville home was under the ever watchful eye
of his grandfather,
Kaiser Wilhelm, the fast.
Meanwhile, Bismarck who act, it's
preparing Ville home for Ruda ship.
The encouraged him to view all things
English with disdain and to reject the
worldview of his parents. Then not
march the ninth 1888 Kaysville home,
the first diet below homes.
Father now inherited the role,
but just a few months into his reign,
he succumbed to Throat Cancer Ville.
Helm now became at Kaiser Wilhelm,
the seconds of Prussia and Germany.
He was 29 years of age and the date
was June the 15th 1888 immediately upon
ascending, sending the Throne Ville home
came into conflict with his advisors.
Chief among them was Otto von Bismarck.
The experienced statesmen advocated a
policy of peaceful relations with the
other heads of states in Europe,
but Ville helm was intent on extending
the territorial borders of Germany and
was ready to pursue an
aggressive international stops.
Bismarck had been the trusted foreign
adviser to Kaiser Wilhelm the first,
but the new Kaiser had no assumptions,
trust for the Statesman for his part.
Bismarck thought once Ville home ascended
to the throne that he would be able to
manipulate and control him. He soon
realized that he'd been very wrong.
They'll Holmes tolerance for Bismarck
reached its limits when the old man tried
to implement an anti socialist policy.
Phil Hill oppose the policy
has every opportunity.
Eventually the two had a heated encounter,
which ended with Ville home demanding
Bismark's resignation. Yeah.
Yeah.
With ms as foreign minister, a balanced
state of peace existed between Germany,
France, and Russia. The Russians,
they now had no confidence in Ville.
Home's ability to maintain the peace
and so they grew closer with France.
The piece between Russia and Germany,
the guns grow increasingly fragile.
In the early 19 hundreds Ville home
focused on building up Germany's navy,
he saw a powerful navy as being a
symbol of Germans position as a world
superpower and he became obsessed
with the idea of huge ships.
Many hours of spent drawing
his own designs of ships.
They also made sure to let the rest of
Europe know how he was building up his
nation's military might.
At the same time that he was
stretching his international muscles,
Ville home was making
domestic improvements.
He reformed public education to
make it available to every child.
He was also an advocate
of the arts and sciences,
starting the Kaiser Wilhelm Society to
advanced scientific research. Ville.
Ham had by now managed do alien aids.
Most of the leaders of Europe,
he was lacking in patients. He had an
explosive temper and it's possessed.
No tact whatsoever.
And infamous example of his ability to
alienate others was when in 1896 he sent
a telegram to President Kruger of the
Transvaal Republic in South Africa.
The message congratulated Crew Agatha
is suppression of the British led
Jamestown rate.
When news of the telegram reached Brisen,
it caused an outcry of rage against
Germany even before this incident.
Even those in the British royal
family who were related to bill helm,
they didn't like him. In addition to
his natural arrogance is over racism,
alienated others.
He constantly warned European leaders of
the yellow peril referring to Japan and
China.
Wally was content's you
alienated the European powers.
Ville home went out of his way to develop
code your relations with the leaders
of the Ottoman Empire.
His first trip to Istanbul was in 1889
he made a deal to sell guns to the
Ottoman army.
Nine years later,
he undertook a month long trip through
the holy lands before heading home.
He professed his undying friendship for
the tax in 1905 Ville home committed,
one of his biggest diplomatic blunders
when he visited a Tangier in Morocco.
There. He met with representatives
of Sultan Abdulaziz
expressing his support for
Moroccans sovereignty.
This was a direct challenge to the French
who has a large military presence in
Morocco. It also further alienated the
Kaiser from the international community,
what became known as the Moroccan
crisis also served to bring previous a
lifelong arrivals,
France and Britain closer together in
their opposition to the aggressive stance
of the German reared up in 1908 Deville
home agreed to an interview for the
British newspaper,
the Daily Telegraph,
seeing it as an opportunity to
strengthen Anglo German relations.
During the interview,
his fiery 10 we've got the better of
him and he managed to insult the British
people numerous times,
as well as insinuating that the Russians
and French had tried to pull Germany
into the second bar war,
the whole interview.
It was a disaster and it
greatly embarrassed the
German people goals were even
made for Ville. Home to Bab, to gate.
In the wake of the fallout
from the interview.
Phil home laid low offer a month he and
merge didn't he immediately forced as
Chancellor Prince Bulow to resign blaming
him for authorizing the disastrous
interview in the first place.
This was a terrible move and it lost in
a lot of the internal support that he
had remaining.
This episode stole away any of the self
confidence that avail home still hat he
fell into a deep state of depression.
All of his energy was thrown into his pet
project of building up the German navy.
His obsession with building more powerful
battleships and the British got his
country into serious financial hardship.
By the beginning of 1914 Ville home had
managed to alienate all of the major
powers in Europe and doing all of the
work that Bismarck had done when they'll
home.
The fast was Kaiser.
One of the few friends that he had was
Ferdinand's the archduke of Austria,
the assassination,
the third and ends on June the 28th of
1914 deeply affected Ville home when it
was revealed this an underground movement
called the black hands was behind the
murder. He extended his full support
in hunting them down. He also, uh,
just Austria,
Hungary to use force against Serbia
in buying that he would back them up.
Bag Dawn by Ville Helm Franz Joseph,
the fast of Austria,
made demands of Salvia that
were impossible to meet
when the deadline to meet
the conditions past without satisfaction.
Australia declared war on Saudi Yap.
In response to this,
Russian troops began to mobilize in
order to defend Serbia from attack home
learns of the Russian
mobilization on July the 30th.
He knew that his treaty obligations with
Austria meant that he was bounced to
declared war on Russia.
He was also convinced that England and
Russia and France and conspired to knock
out Germany. This meant that he would
be faced with attack from two fronts.
The Russians from the east, and it's
the British and French from the West.
Back in 1905 prominent German general by
the name of von Schlieffen had devised
a plan of attack on France.
Now the generals nephew Helmuth von Moltke
adapted the plan to fight a two front
war.
The plan calls for a preemptive strike
on the weaker country that we could come.
It was France. Why is that attack
had been successfully carried out.
The focus could then switch to Russia
Ville helm. He was sold on the plan,
but as general not so much.
They were convinced that Russia was not
prepared for war in wanting to strike to
the east first.
The reality was that the Russians were
indeed ready and had the army mobilized
to defend the Serbians Ville home.
Build his way,
though in the Schlieffen plan
was put into action. However,
it proved to be a disaster.
As the German war effort nudged
Donville homes influenced,
became less and less as
Germany's top military officials
field marshal pull them,
Hindenburg and general. Eric
alluded, Dorf took the reins.
The Kaiser busy didn't self with awarding
medals and officiating at military
ceremonies.
His moods follow day.
Manic depressive passion fluctuating
between euphoria that Germany was about to
crush the allies and dispatch all was
lost as the war drew to a conclusion.
In the closing months of 1918 us,
President Woodrow Wilson announced that
the German Kaiser would not be permitted
to take part in any peace negotiations.
This effectively made Phil
home a lame duck leader
as gem and capitulation drew ever naira.
A revolts broke out in Germany.
The vast majority of people,
they were just sick and tired of
this bundling arrogant leader.
There were calls for his abdication,
Still Ville,
him vacillated even
without any support at all.
He thought that he could retain at
least one or even two of his crowns,
but the constitution that stipulated
that the two crowns were to be forever
intertwined. Application from one thrown
meant abdication from both of them.
On November the ninth chancellor Prince
Max von Barden announced that Ville helm
was abdicating. He did this in order
to stem the tide of revolution,
but the chancellor's efforts,
they backfired and he
himself was forced to resign.
However, the next day, November the
10th of Wilhelm fled to the Netherlands.
At this time, he had still not
abdicated. Over the next weeks. However,
his top military advisor,
Paul von Hindenburg advise and abdication
the general made it clear that Ville
helm did not enjoy the support of the
army and so they would not back him when
they returned from the war. Realizing
that the situation was untenable.
Wilhelm faced reality and abdicated on
November the 28th 1918 the treaty of
Versailles which officially ended the
war with signs on June the 28th 1919 in
branded Kaysville helm is a war criminal
and stipulated that he'd be prosecuted
for a supreme offense against
international morality and the sanctity of
treaties, the Netherlands
governments. However,
they refused to extradite Philhealth.
The situation was actually pleasing to
President Wilson who felt that the trial
and prosecution of the Kaiser would only
prolonged tensions between Germany and
the rest of Europe.
The best thing would just be for bill
home to remain in the Netherlands.
Ville home purchased a house
in the municipality of dawn.
He would remain there
for the rest of his life.
The new German Weimar Republic allows
him to transport some of his possessions
there from his old palace and Potsdam.
He now made it his life's mission to clear
his name of wrongdoing and it came to
the war in April, 1921 villa homes wife
Donna. She died a few months earlier.
Their son had committed suicide.
These deaths,
a devastating blow to the XL Kaiser.
In 1922 William wrote a memoir in which
he defended his international policy and
but forth his case that he was not
responsible for a war that had led to 10
million deaths. At the same time, he
became socially active in the Netherlands,
entertaining high profile guests and
engaging his passions for archeology and
hunting. He also started a new hobby,
wood chopping, despite his with a arm.
He became quite proficient at it,
chopping down thousands of trees during
the last two decades of his life.
In mid 1922 bill Holm,
that princess mine reus of Greece,
there was an immediate mutual attraction
and they were married on November the
ninth
during the 1930 is villa home paid
close attention to the rise of Nazi-ism.
He never embraced the
pottery or it's neater,
but did hold out hope that Hitler
would eventually restore the monarchy.
It was his vain hope that his oldest
grandson would be appointed as Kaiser.
Once that occurred,
his wife,
how mean even sent a request
to that effect out of Hitler,
but the fear of being wasn't interested
in fact seat and held a special hatred
favilla him blaming him for the disastrous
defeat in the first world war as well
as actions became more extreme.
The former leader of Germany observing
from his ex out home in the Netherlands
became increasingly alarmed at what
was taking place under Nazi rule.
When he had heard that Hitler ordered
the murder of the wife of the chancellor.
He commented,
we have ceased to live under the rule
of law and everyone must be prepared for
the possibility that the Nazis will push
their way in and put them up against a
wall. Villa homes antipathy
towards Hitler became personal.
He believed that the Futura was turning
his cherish and military into a gang of
thugs. However, has hit the guns at rack
of international military victories,
fell home, changed his tune,
and again preys upon him.
When the Netherlands were occupied in
May of 1940 he received the following
message from Phil Helm,
my fear.
I congratulate you and hope that
under your marvelous leadership,
the German monarchy will be
restored completely Hitler.
I wasn't amused. In fact,
he referred to as home as an idiot.
That's impression was reinforced
when following the fall of Paris.
He received this message,
congratulations, you have won.
Using my trips under
the German occupation,
Phil Holmes House was kept under German.
God,
this was more there to provide protection
for the old Kaiser who was now 82 than
to imprison him.
It was done at the behest
of a Nazi general and when
hit the found out about it,
he was furious and had the general fired
Geyserville homeless second dies on June
the fourth 1941 of a pulmonary embolism
in the death of Hitler saw an
opportunity to make political capital.
He ordered the body be returned
to Berlin for a state funeral.
He saw this as a way of showing to the
German people that the Third Reich was
just a continuation of
the old German empire,
but Hedlands wishes they were denied.
Phil home had made it clear to the Dutch
authorities that he would never return
to Germany until the
monarchy was restored.
The Dutch government has seeded to these
wishes and the body remained in the
Netherlands where he was
given a military funeral.
He was buried in a mausoleum
on the property of dawn.
That was his Dutch home there.
It remains to this very day,
so I really hope you found my
video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe.
Brand new videos several times a week,
and if you want something else
that's a bit different. Indeed,
it's not actually a youtube channel.
I do a podcast called the brain food show.
If you just search brain food one
word in Itunes, you'll find it.
Go give it a listen and let me
know what you think and as always,
thank you for watching.